[Music]
shamatha is famous for anything
it's
for
lack of a better word he's a great
talker there are 150 and they're all men
that run the world period full stop he
is almost becoming one of those one
named people at least in financial
circles trump jamaat shamath he's brash
he's not shy about his opinions your
behaviors you don't realize it but you
are being programmed goldman sachs sucks
who cares not no smart person goes
towards a gold some people would compare
him to elon musk which also uses his
social media influence to communicate
with investors for some target company
that's the appeal because you get the
instant name recognition once you're
associated with gemma
so he was somebody that i saw as one of
the biggest boosters of this crazy
bubble and also one of its biggest
beneficiaries in particular he was one
of the leaders of the boom for special
purpose acquisition companies otherwise
known as spax
no one quite knows exactly why the
market for spax exploded but everyone
gives jamaat a lot of credit
[Music]
[Applause]
when i got back from paternity leave
earlier this year i saw that
markets seem to have gone totally crazy
investors were buying up all sorts of
stocks with no regard for the company's
earnings or
profits or any of the sort of
traditional things that
boring investors used to look at video
game retailer gamestop is set to
continue their head spinning ascent
today and then of course this amc
phenomenon we saw this wild ride for amc
investors on this retail trade driven
frenzy everyone was having a lot of fun
driving socks up to the moon as they say
and i wanted to look at
a promoter who was
encouraging this boom uh startup grind
welcome to champ let's hear it right now
and i've found
a guy by the name of jamaat palihapatiya
i have lore i've worked in three
of like the top five internet businesses
ever created i didn't have to look very
hard he's super popular on twitter he's
got million and a half followers and
he's always talking about the stocks
that he's taking public how great these
are to invest in we are involved in
probably
10 to 15 billion dollar unicorn
companies
polly happened to likes to tell the
story of his upbringing because it's a
bit of a
rags to riches
american dream type story rich or poor
uh on well my parents were
kind of ruling class in sri lanka and
then in the civil war we emigrated to
canada and i grew up on welfare my dad
struggled to find a job worked at a
photocopy store for a while when i got
my first job it was at burger king i
take the money and i have to give it to
my parents and we would buy bus passes
he
went to the university of waterloo where
he
studied electrical engineering after
college
he did what a lot of people do who are
wanting to make some money he went into
investment banking traded derivatives
my first job out of college um
i made 55 000 and the reason i like that
job again it kind of like it played on
my desire to take risk and
um you know quote unquote gamble but
when he
didn't get a bonus one year got angry
and quit moved to
california to seek his fortune in
the first.com bubble i wanted to be
emancipated i wanted to like find my own
path to like be able to like not have to
be a subject of the man
he
went over to
facebook headquarters
for
what he didn't really think was a a job
interview at least as he's told the
story he met with
one of facebook's top executives who was
kind of put out by
this person
acting like chemoth was there to
to be interviewed and at that time
facebook was still
just starting to build off its roots
with on college campuses and high
schools
and chamath convinced
founder mark zuckerberg who was then
just about 23 years old that what
facebook really needed was a dedicated
team to devoted to growth and that he
was the person to to run the team by the
time he left facebook in 2011
the company had
almost a billion users and chamath had
made a name for himself and also started
making
angel investments on the side with his
personal money it took me into my early
40s to say
what is what is going to change this
this sort of lingering burning sensation
in my stomach and so i just went off to
fix these things and professionally
the most important thing is i said i'm
building somebody else's company
and i'm sure all of you guys founders
have felt that moment where it's like am
i building the thing that i want or am i
building the thing that somebody else
wants after he left facebook he tore
into them paulie apatia burns down what
he built he's imploding what's the story
it said that they were ripping apart the
social fabric of how society works
the short-term dopamine
driven feedback loops that we have
created are destroying how society works
in 2011 chamoth left facebook to start
his own venture capital fund he called
it social capital i wanted to make money
for people that i thought were
interesting and good i didn't want to
make money for some other random person
some endowment some pension fund some
university that isn't doing anything
good with the money he had a plan to
automate the investing process to remove
biases
and he did make
several investments into companies with
those aims but as it turned out best
bets the ones that really made money
were
more traditional more similar to what
other firms were doing
like slack the business chat software or
amazon which he
said was going to rise sharply at a time
when people thought maybe it already was
overvalued
got into bitcoin very early
recommended tesla
in 2018 despite great returns at social
capital absolutely obliterating the
market we're probably like
well like the public side vehicle is
probably like 30 points of alpha above
the nasdaq i mean it's it's really good
the company ran into a lot of trouble
high-level executives clashed with
chamath and left investors complained
about a change in focus and chamath was
left with what was a
much smaller firm managing mostly his
own money this led him to have more time
to devote to a side project he'd started
a year earlier called a spac tech spec
and spac specs a spac is a shell company
that goes public they raise money from
public investors
and the management team of the shell
vehicle then have two years to find an
acquisition
and during those two years the shell
company trades publicly on the exchange
tell me from your perspective is there a
limit investors give money to a sponsor
who
says that they're going to use it to
buy something and for every
ten dollars that you hand to the sponsor
the sponsor gives you
one share and these shares are traded on
the stock
market spak got a bad name in the 80s
when many of the people running them
would raise money and then just
steal it for themselves they were
rehabilitated by
a broker in long island
named david nussbaum came up with a
important protection for investors which
was that
they would
raise money and then put it in the bank
instead of stealing it
when a company goes public in a
traditional ipo
they are
very limited in what they can say about
their
prospects for the future
the underwriter of the ipo they
project that say we're going to make a
billion dollars next year that investors
could sue them if it doesn't come true
one of the biggest advantage for
companies to go public through a stack
is that they can market forward-looking
projections which really benefits the
company that don't have any revenue at
this very point that they want to go
public so chamath has really become like
the poster of this bag boom given the
fact that virgin galactic now just
directly listed on the exchange through
social capital's spec do you see this as
a model that other companies are going
to adopt i do and i hope that this is a
really good litmus test and a case study
he was the person that kind of started
this whole
frenzy in 2019 when he took virgin
galactic public i think that we found
the absolute best company something that
will thrive in the public markets and
frankly something that's going to
capture an enormous amount of consumer
interest
giving the average person a chance to
own a bit of space one of his thing is
every time he does a deal he published
his rationale behind
making this investment and people really
love it and i think as a result it
really brought people's attention that
this is not your very complicated
financial engineering but
it's an instrument that your mom-and-pop
investors could could participate
investors were so eager to get a piece
of chamas deal that even before
his specs would announce a target when
they were just piles of money
people were paying 15 dollars a share so
you're essentially paying 15 dollars
for
a 10 bill with the hopes that chamoth is
going to buy something so great that
you'll make up that deficit later to me
at least much more interesting to say
you failed trying something crazy and
huge than something incremental and just
frankly you know the fourth order
derivative of something that was done 10
years ago in 2019 there was about 12
billion dollar raids and news specs and
so far this year
just five months and we've seen a
hundred billion raised globally now it
seems like practically every
underemployed rich guy with some name
recognition has his own spec
there are specs advised by retired
athletes like alex rodriguez or
shaquille o'neal
and facts advised by washed-up
politicians like paul ryan or john
delaney there's even one spack that has
both nba legend david robinson
and former senate majority leader bill
frist
working on it
paulie habitia has raised six packs so
far
more than four billion dollars his
vision is to raise
26 specs he names his specs
alphabetically so ipo a and he's now
raised up to ipof
i researched each of the companies that
paulie hapatiya had taken public
one that really caught my attention was
clover health we are really excited
after months of diligence and work to
announce a merger between ipoc and
health to take clover health public he
talked up this company like it was a
tech company that was about to
change health care
clover is already growing two to three
times faster than their next nine
nearest competitors
what that's created is a business that
last year alone did almost 460 million
dollars of revenue
and in 2023 we'll do 1.7 billion dollars
of revenue chamath always tweets a
one-page thesis about why you should buy
whatever stock he's pitching and in the
one for clover he said the company had
41 000 members now but would have 273
000 next year so i decided to dig in a
little bit
clover had actually been around for
almost a decade when
the merger with tremoth's back was
announced
and
it's lost money the whole time it's
missed its growth targets it was clear
that this was really
a smallish insurance company that
almost exclusively sold
medicare advantage plans to older people
in new jersey they were losing
a couple hundred million dollars a year
the company is saying that
it's put all that behind it because it's
developed a new technology that's the
culmination of all its research and this
technology is called
clover assistant the clover system is a
web application and a physician uses it
every visit that they have with one of
our members clover says
that this technology will
enable all doctors to offer better care
but i spoke to
several former employees of clover and
they said that the rollout was rockier
than the company had presented it
and they said that many doctors who are
signed up to use this technology
don't actually use it themselves and
when you look at clover's financial
results the type of stuff that
you'd be forced to rely on in a
traditional ipo instead of a spac you
see that
every quarter the company is
spending more money than it makes
[Music]
for a while it seemed like
everything he touched turned to gold and
if you had bought blindly into all of
his deals you would have made a lot of
money but sentiment changed
in february a short seller published a
report that
shocked clover investors it was
from
a group called hindenburg research
and it's really
run by
a guy named nate anderson
out of his
apartment in manhattan anderson called
out chamoth and he said that
chamoth had
misled investors clover wasn't really a
tech company
and that in fact
doctors didn't like using its software
anderson's report proved to be pretty
well timed the market for specs peaked
around february and from february to
march
average back dropped about seventeen
percent
and poly hapatius backs which had
climbed higher
also dropped further in virgin galactic
his first back
he
sold 300 million worth of stock more
than enough to cover what he put in and
on cloverhealth about doubled his money
despite the stock dropping quite a bit
since he announced the deal i think that
spax are very much here to stay
back in the you know using the language
of inequality it evens the playing field
it democratizes access to high growth
companies
since that initial slide
some of jamaa's facts have recovered a
bit
but
most investors who bought in early of
the year when the bubble was inflating
are still way underwater
chamath didn't respond to a request to
be interviewed for this video
the appeal of chamoth was that if he put
his name on something it might triple
now
it's unclear whether
he's going to be able to keep raising
them or to keep acquiring companies at
the pace that he had if a
bank like jp morgan underwrites one bad
ipo
it doesn't affect their brand so much
because they've got so many to
that they've done over the years but
paulie habetia's brand his identity was
sort of
built on this idea that he can't miss
and now that
he has missed it's not clear if he'll be
able to to keep this up
[Music]
you